So,
hi guys,
my name is Nate ruling.
I sit across the street over in sales,
look,
got the Microsoft business.
So nice to meet you.
Um,
we're here today because of a good friend of mine.
Eric Faye was talking to me about this fantastic story and this incredible woman
and a team behind her as well.
Uh,
so he asked,
you know,
hey,
would it be possible to have a chat at Google?
And I said,
absolutely.
Let's,
let's do this.
Um,
so I have the pleasure of introducing Barbara.
I Aerosmith young today and today's talk is going to be about a personal journey
into the world of the brain,
shaping the mind.
Such a cool title,
right?
Very exciting.
Um,
I've got three kids,
so I'm watching my kids develop over the years since it's been incredible to me
and I cannot wait to see what we're about to see.
So I'm going to be quick.
Uh,
but before I bring her up a bit more about her,
she holds a bachelor in Applied Science Child Studies,
a master's in school psychology from the University of Toronto.
Her work began in 1978,
uh,
as,
and it's been recognized as one of the first examples of practical application
of neural plasticity,
which simply means,
uh,
you know,
the ability of the brain to change and rewire itself over one's lifetime.
It's fantastic.
Uh,
the genesis of the program lays in Barbara Zone,
journey of discovery and innovation to overcome her learning disabilities.
Um,
a description of which appears in her book that you guys have.
So thank you for bringing those today.
And then there'll be a signing afterwards.
Uh,
and uh,
the name of that book is titled the Woman Who Changed Her brain.
Many reviewers have written about her book,
uh,
to share one of the quotes.
I really liked this one,
a,
it will open your mind to new possibilities and how to deal with traffic jams in
the brain.
So I know a lot of us,
especially Google,
we have a lot of traffic jams.
Um,
sounds,
sounds fitting.
Um,
her life has been a quest to help individuals address learning difficulties,
uh,
so they can experience the ease and joy of learning,
as well as achieve their dreams.
There.
This program is in over 91 schools across several countries,
Canada,
US,
Australia,
New Zealand,
Malaysia,
Thailand and South Korea.
So really excited to have her here.
Let's give her a warm welcome.
Thank you.
Okay.
And I'm sorry guys,
one more thing before we start.
Please silence your phones.
Thank you.
Well,
I want to thank Eric Faye for making the introduction and,
and uh,
thank you,
Nate for providing me the opportunity to speak about what I'm most passionate
about,
which is our human brain is incredible complexity and the possibility for
change.
Um,
it's sort of what I'm probably most passionate about in the world and my life
and my work is really been an exploration of the territory of the human brain.
How it makes us uniquely who we are.
Because when we think about our brain,
it filters our perceptions of ourselves and our understanding of ourselves,
our understanding of other people are understanding the world and understanding
of our relationship to that.
So really,
really critical in terms of mediating our experience.
And to me,
what's really promising is not only does our brain shape who we are,
but now we know what this concept of neuroplasticity that we can actually shape
our brain if we can understand how we can harness those principles.
And also I think what's really interesting,
we often hear the comment about he or she is just not good at that.
Um,
and we also attribute often attribute,
you know,
not being good at something as coming out of maybe an emotional base.
You know,
that person is just rude or,
or um,
you know,
they're not good socially.
And I would like to encourage people to start to look at behavior through a
cognitive lens.
Behaviors multiply determined.
It's not just cognitive,
but I think we ignore the cognitive.
If there's any part of our brain that isn't fully operational or functioning,
it will have an impact in terms of our behavior.
And I'm going to take you a little bit into that world today.
So science has taught us that,
as I said,
our brain really does shape us.
And if we think about how complex it is,
we have something on the order of 86 billion neurons that we're carrying around
in our head.
And to put that into perspective,
the world's population is somewhere between seven and 8 billion.
So incredible complexity.
And we have several hundred trillion connections or super highways in the brain
connecting different regions for neurotransmission and communication.
And again,
to put that into perspective,
we have more connections in our brain than all the stars in the Milky Way
Galaxy.
So incredibly complex and we can't really escape our brain because we carry it
everywhere we go.
Um,
also what I find really fascinating is no two brains are exactly alike.
So if you think about somebody that you know well or you look at somebody
sitting next to you and you note that there are physical differences between the
two of you,
I may have different eye color,
different shape of your nose,
different shape of your ears.
They're actually more differences between your two brains than all of those
physical differences combined.
So our brain really does make us uniquely who we are.
And to me.
So I said what's really,
really promising is this concept of neuroplasticity.
We now know that we can actually grow new neurons in the brain,
in the hippocampus,
which is really important for memory and for learning.
Um,
we know that we can increase neurotransmitter's.
We know that we can increase the branches,
the dendrites on the neurons to enhance neurotransmission so we can actually
change our brain.
So my story begins with my brain and it's really a story of a quest and the hunt
for a solution to my very severe learning disabilities that were identified in
grade one.
So it's a very personal story,
but it's also universal in that each and every one of us has a brain that
impacts our functioning.
And if we think about having a brain that's capable and incapable at the same
time,
that's the experience of someone with a learning difficulty there.
Things that we can do very easily.
And then there are other things that with the best will in the world,
they're really incredibly challenging.
And that certainly was my experience.
So for me,
growing up,
I lived in a world that was about as intelligible as Lewis Carroll's poem,
the Jabberwocky.
Um,
I didn't understand it at the time that,
you know,
I couldn't process language.
It was almost like I heard the words.
I mean I knew what the words were,
but I struggled to interpret them to attach meaning to them.
So for me,
I could understand things very concretely.
I mean if somebody said it's raining outside,
which I understand that does quite a bit here in Seattle,
um,
I could understand that because I could conjure up a visual image of rain.
But as soon as it got abstract conceptual,
it was impossible to me.
Something as simple as,
you know,
I couldn't understand how my ENT could also be my mother's sister.
I could not understand how could somebody have to relationships in terms of
numbers.
I mean I can understand one,
cause I could,
you know,
put one object up here I can understand for,
cause I could line up,
you know,
four objects.
You put that one over top of a four,
which is a relationship of a part to a hole.
It meant nothing to me.
Bigger than,
greater than,
less than under,
over anything that we had a relational connotation was incredibly difficult or
impossible for me to understand.
My notebooks were filled with diagrams.
I used my right hemisphere to try to interpret language by making drawings to
try to connect the relationships.
Things as simple as jokes.
I didn't understand jokes because it depends on irony.
So,
you know,
not wanting to feel left out as a child.
What I would do is I would laugh as much as everybody else was laughing because
I didn't want to feel left out,
but I had no idea what they were laughing at.
Um,
I was really vulnerable to con artists because how do you understand that you're
being conned?
You hear logical inconsistencies in what person or somebody saying,
well,
for me there was no logic in my world.
So there were no logical inconsistencies so easily.
Um,
you know,
believed what people told me.
And something as simple as telling time.
I couldn't read an analog clock.
In fact,
I couldn't read an analog clock until I was 26 and created my first exercise for
myself because to interpret time you have to understand the relationship between
the hour hand in the minute hand.
And I couldn't understand that relationship.
Um,
so any kind of abstract ideas,
concepts were hard.
I got identified in grade one is being rigid and stubborn and I really was rigid
and stubborn.
But again,
not coming from an emotional place,
it was a cognitive difficulty because for me any kind of understanding was so
hard.
One.
So if I came to understand something,
I wanted to hold onto it for dear life.
And if somebody said,
well think about another way of doing something,
think about an alternative.
It felt like I had to let go of this.
That was so hard for me to grasp,
to integrate something else and I just felt my whole world would fall apart.
So maybe in your lives,
you know,
somebody that's really rigid and stubborn and it might be because they can't
compare and contrast,
they can't see alternatives or way decisions are differences.
And what ended up having to happening in my life,
um,
was that very fragmented and fractured view of my world because nothing
connected.
There was no cause and effect in my world.
In fact,
I thought there was some puppet master up there pulling strings because I
couldn't understand why things happened.
It led to an incredibly fractured and fragmented sense of myself.
And I've described my world is living in a fog where meaning was just a femoral
and it would disappear into a mist of,
of just uncertainty and kind of joke that I lived in Amygdala hell.
I was terrified all the time because I didn't understand the meaning of what was
happening around me.
So,
and if that wasn't enough,
I had another difficulty.
So I had multiple what would be considered multiple learning disabilities.
So I struggled to register the location of sensation on the left side of my
body.
So most people,
if you go to put your hand on a hot burner,
your brain is going to tell you pain is going to tell you pain in your left
hand,
pull it up.
And I mean,
it's going to be just an automatic process.
I mean,
you're not going to stop and think about it.
Well,
for me,
my brain would tell me pain,
but it wouldn't register where the pain was coming from.
So I'd leave my hand on the hot burner.
Um,
which really wasn't very good idea.
So I learned probably around age three or four that I had to watch the left side
of my body because it would do things.
There's almost like an alien being.
It would do things.
I slammed a car door on my head once with my left hand and you know,
shattered a tooth.
Um,
my mother was convinced by probably about age five that I would not live very
long because I was so accident prone,
but it was a cognitive area that just wouldn't register the location of
sensation.
And imagine me on a sports team,
right?
I mean,
I struggled academically.
Nobody wanted me on their sports team in school.
And I understood why.
Like I truly wasn't an asset because I was so clumsy.
Um,
and ended up,
you know,
being bruised and banged and kind of battered and then imagine me driving a car
if I didn't know where the left side of my body was.
Once I started to drive a car,
I didn't know where the left side of that car was.
So not only was my body bruised and banged my,
well it was actually my parents' car cause when I first started driving,
their car was bruised and banged and dented on the left side by extension.
And then there was another area that wasn't working,
um,
area that allows you to represent three dimensional space inside your head.
Um,
I couldn't do that so I couldn't create maps inside my head.
Geography,
geometry,
any activity,
chess checkers that involve a spatial component was really,
really hard for me.
And again,
things that we take for granted,
like crossing the street,
um,
was really terrifying because when you cross the street,
what you actually do kind of automatically,
she create a mental map of where you are relative to that car coming at you.
Um,
I couldn't do that.
So I had no idea where I was relative to that car.
So my compensation was to walk blocks out of my way to find a stop sign or a
stop light where a new cars had to stop and then we'd be relatively safe
crossing.
Or my other strategy was to wait by the side of the road until somebody else
came along to cross.
And I would follow them and I would pray that they didn't have the same
difficulty that I did in that we get across safely.
And I used to joke that I would be a safe crossing the I or crossing the street
with my eyes closed is with my eyes open,
which was probably pretty accurate because I couldn't do that spacial repertoire
representation and I would always get lost because for me there were no maps.
Um,
like,
you know,
I didn't even understand the streets connected,
so I couldn't hold any kind of spatial representation in my head.
So anytime I went somewhere I had to calculate in what I called last time.
So I would always give myself extra time because I knew I would get lost,
you know,
several times before I finally found my way.
And so those were some of the areas of the main ones that I struggled with.
And so for me,
when I began my schooling in the 1950s,
it was in the time of what I call the Pre neuroplastic paradigm.
So when I started in grade one,
the traditional belief was if you have a learning problem or there's a problem
in your brain,
nothing you can do about it.
Basically the brain you're born with,
it's a brain you die with.
There was no concept of neuroplasticity.
In fact,
people believed there was no such thing as neuroplasticity.
Most people.
Um,
so in grade one I overheard my teacher tell my mother that I had a mental block
because this was before the term learning disability hadn't even been invented.
Um,
and being very concrete,
I just actually imagined that I had a piece of wood,
like a nice wooden cube lodged in my head that made learning really difficult.
And later I learned I didn't have a wooden cube,
but in a sense I had blockages.
There were parts of my brain that weren't working properly.
But imagine like in grade one,
I was given a life sentence,
told that I would never learn like other children,
that all of my academic career would be an incredible struggle.
And that I was really condemned to living in that,
that world of disconnected elements and confusion and fog.
And that really was my experience going through school.
And when I did eventually learn how to read and to write and do kind of simple
numeracy,
I used my strengths.
I have a,
um,
verbatim auditory memory.
I can listen to things and just like a little tape recorder,
remember them.
Um,
and I have a photographic visual memory,
so,
you know,
I can look at print and remember and that's what got me through.
And I had incredible drive and determination.
Um,
so I never understood anything I could memorize it and then,
you know,
match it up on the exam and I would get anywhere from 10% on an exam to 100%
depending if I made the right match,
the 10%,
you know,
I made a really bad match cause I didn't really understand what was being asked.
The hundred percent I made a better match,
probably really didn't understand what was going on,
but I just was lucky to make a better match.
But what my teachers would conclude if I could get 100% at one point and I got
10%,
I must not have worked very hard for that 10% and I worked as hard for the 10%
decided for the hundred percent.
So certainly,
you know,
it was a confusing picture for teachers.
So I was very,
very lucky.
My father was a scientist and an vendor,
um,
had something on the order of 40 patents.
He conditioned electricity and I kind of caught that creative passion from him.
I really didn't understand anything that he was doing,
but I felt that,
you know,
that desire to create.
And he told me as I was growing up,
he said,
if there's a problem in your life and there's no solution out there in the
world,
he said,
it's your responsibility to go out and find a solution to the problem.
Kind of probably like what all of you do here.
You find solutions to problems.
And he also said something really wise that I've taken with me through my life.
He said,
don't be limited by conventional wisdom.
the rest of the world tells you you can't do this.
He said,
ignore them.
Don't listen.
Go out and do it.
So I sat on a quest to try to find a solution to my difficulties.
And for me the solution came to brilliant researchers.
Uh,
the first one,
Alexander Luria,
Russian neuropsychologist,
doing a lot of work in Russia after World War II where there are a lot of
Russian soldiers with very localized headwinds.
And what he would do was investigate clinically by giving them tests to try to
understand if there's damage to this part of the brain,
what can the person no longer do?
Therefore,
by inference,
what does that part of the brain do?
And he's really one of the seminal thinkers in neuropsychology and neuroscience
that started to map the brain,
um,
many,
many years ago.
So he helped with identification of,
of the function of different parts of the brain.
And I came across a book that he had written called the man with the shattered
world.
And it was a story of a Russian soldier who in 1943 in the battle of Smolensk
had a shrapnel wound to her,
part of his brain and the left hemisphere,
very localized wound.
And as I read this man's story,
I thought this man is living my life,
you know,
several decades earlier and halfway around the world in Russia,
he was using the same language in his journal,
talking about living in a fog where meaning was a femoral and would disappear
that I was using in my journal,
you know,
decades later.
And,
and in Canada.
So I had an epiphany at that point cause I knew I had terrible problems,
but I had no idea what the source of the problems were.
And to solve a problem,
you kind of have to get an idea of what the nature of the problem is.
So now I knew the nature,
I knew it was part of my brain that wasn't working properly.
So that was great.
But then what do I do about that?
The next piece of the puzzle came in the work of Mark Rosen Schwag and he was in
Berkeley working with rats cause they're a lot easier to work with them people.
Um,
and what he was doing was putting rats in a really enriched environment.
We were a lot of stimulation then he would compare them to rats in a normal or
an unenriched environment.
And he would put them in little rat intelligence tests,
which is running a,
and he found those rights that had had the enriched experience.
We're able to learn the maze much more efficiently and effectively.
And then because they were ratzy cut their heads open and looked at their
brains,
um,
and well,
and what he found was the brains had changed physiologically for those rats that
had the enrichment.
There were more neurotransmitters,
there were more,
you can see the slide of the neuron more dendright.
So more synaptic connections if they're more dendritic branches,
um,
increase more glial cells,
enlarge cappelary so more blood flowing to the,
to the regions.
I think there was something like 12 physiological variables that it changed with
the enrichment that led to,
he inferred the improved performance on the mazes.
So I had to infer,
even though nobody was looking at it at that time,
or believe that if rats had neuroplasticity,
humans,
like we must have neuroplasticity.
And I kind of thought that we probably had more neuroplasticity than rats.
So I thought if I can take Laurie's work,
um,
and understand the nature of what that part of the brain is supposed to do,
like what's this job and what's its function?
Maybe I could find an activity or a task that would stimulate it to make it
work.
So I figured it might not work because the rest of the world was saying it
couldn't.
But what did I have to lose other than time?
And it was 25,
26 I couldn't tell time.
So I figured,
what does it really matter?
Well,
let me try it.
I'm sorry.
And so the age of 26,
I said out with the first exercise and what did I use?
I use clocks.
Not that I wanted to get better telling time,
but the concept is you need to force the brain to do what it's designed to do.
But what is really difficult,
and I couldn't do the relational piece.
So I use the clocks to force processing relationships and I got really fast at
reading a two handed clock.
Um,
really accurate.
I mean it was pretty visible at the beginning.
Um,
and that was great.
So now I can tell time,
but I didn't feel any cognitive change.
And to drive neuroplastic change,
you have to increase novelty and complex complexity.
So what I did is I kept adding more hands,
more relationships,
and now we have a 10 hand o'clock,
which anybody can benefit.
Like the only two people that have ever looked at it and interpreted.
One had discovered quasars radio meeting galaxies.
He was an astronomer and the other was a physicist from Harvard.
So I knew I was onto something with this really advanced level.
Um,
and in fact,
right now I'm talking to a university of Spain in Spain and they're looking at
putting that reasoning exercise into their university.
So every student will go into a cognitive lab and work on that exercise four
hours a week and over a 10 month span will supercharge that cognitive function
in terms of being able to reason.
And it's that ability to process relationship simultaneously is insight.
You know,
where you like all this information,
disparate information comes together and you say,
Aha,
that's what that means.
That's what this,
this function,
excuse me is,
and also what I found interesting is,
um,
I've worked with a number of psychiatrists,
my,
my head schools in Toronto,
and then the snake mentioned their schools all around the world that implement
this program.
And if somebody has this problem and they can't benefit from insight therapy
because insight therapy means that you have to make cause and effect.
You have to see relationships between your behavior and emotions and other
people's actions.
And as students work on this exercise,
if they're in a therapeutic process,
what the psychiatrist or psychologist always report is at the level of it's
about,
you know,
the four relationship will live relationship level of the exercise.
They start to benefit from insight therapy.
So really very profound capacity.
Not that's just going to affect the person in school,
but in their whole life.
And I've had some students that have come to me that had been misdiagnosed as
having Asperger's,
which is a high functioning autism,
um,
because they have a severe difficulty in this function.
And as we address this function,
it's very clear that they don't have Asperger's.
It was just they couldn't connect,
um,
meaning to situations.
So they walked around totally disengaged and not able to relate to the world.
So,
um,
pretty important area.
And as I worked on this and saw the change for me,
what happened was I could now start to live in what I call real time,
whereas before I lived in,
when I called lag time,
because if I listen to the conversation,
um,
I would memorize it.
I wouldn't have that little tape recorder going and I would walk away and maybe
go over it and over and over for two,
three hours to try to understand what were those people saying.
And in some cases I could and in some cases I couldn't.
But even if I could,
it was three hours after the conversation.
So I couldn't be part of that human discourse.
Now I could listen to somebody,
I could understand this.
They were talking,
I could actually make a comment in,
interject,
understand what they said back to me.
I was actually part of human discourse and it was very,
very profound.
I could also now grasp math concepts.
I could understand fractions.
I went back and taught myself all of elementary,
high school and college mathematics.
And now I can understand that from first principles rather than just memorizing
formulas and plugging in numbers.
Um,
I was no longer rigid because I could contrast and compare and weigh decisions
and see alternatives.
I can understand jokes.
Um,
I could tell time and I was no longer vulnerable to con artists.
So all of that changed as a result of one cognitive exercise.
So then I thought,
you know,
can I create an exercise to address the two other problems that I talked about?
Uh,
the first one,
the SMAD is sensory Cortex,
which there you have two strips in either side of your brain.
Um,
the somatic sensory cortex here controls registering and location of sensation
on your left side.
And then this one controls the right side.
So I knew there to create an exercise,
I had to do something with my eyes closed because my compensation was with my
eyes watching what that side of my body was doing and really regulate movement
through vision,
not through sensory feedback.
So it created a whole complex exercise of doing movements.
Um,
you know,
with that side of my body,
I,
with my eyes closed and overcame that problem,
I can now register sensation on the left side of my body.
That location of sensation.
Um,
I don't bump into things.
I don't trip over my feet,
all of that because I didn't know if I went to walk out a door,
I just as likely hit the doorframe as go through the middle of the door because
I didn't know where the side of my body was.
So address that.
Also,
you know,
if I picked up something in my left hand,
the first row in the audience might end up wearing it because I couldn't
regulate movements.
So I would over move or under move or drop things.
I can do all that now.
And to me,
what's powerful if we can understand this concept of neuroplasticity is we're
not teaching skills.
We're not teaching content.
We're not teaching the person how to do,
um,
you know,
or learn an activity.
We're changing the brain's capacity to then learn to learn content,
to learn strategies,
to learn information.
And given that we carry our brain with us everywhere is incredibly powerful to
go under the content into the brain and stimulate that function.
And then the other area in the pridal,
this is a spatial area.
And again,
um,
I knew to create an exercise there that I had to do something with a spatial
component and do it over and over again.
So I created an exercise,
um,
and saw the change.
And now I think in the last three years I've gotten around the world a few times
I'm talking about this work and I don't get lost.
I can actually read maps,
um,
and I can navigate,
I can actually go to Ikea and buy one of those,
you know,
um,
bookcases or cupboards and go from a two dimensional representation and build
three dimensional representation,
which before I couldn't,
I would put the back of the bookcase on upside down and backwards.
Um,
because you can't translate,
you know,
two dimensional representation into three dimensional space.
I can do that now.
Um,
and for me,
those words,
some assembly required before would strike terror into my heart.
I mean,
now I know I can assemble things.
And interestingly,
um,
my mother,
some of these are genetic inherited.
My mother and I both had severe difficulty and these things work on a continuum.
You can be exceptionally strong in an area,
you can have average functioning,
you can have a mild problem,
moderate problem,
severe problem.
So anywhere on the continuum,
my mother and I were at the severe end of this and as a child getting into the
car with my mother,
I mean she had a good attitude.
She has,
it's going to be an adventure,
um,
because neither of us had any maps in our head.
So we kind of knew where we were starting.
We knew sort of where we wanted to end up,
but it was like a black hole in between.
Um,
and she said,
we'll always get there,
which we always did and we never got there the same way twice.
Um,
but you know,
it was an adventure,
but it's like an older and kind of understood more about these,
these cognitive functions.
I asked her,
did this ever like have an impact on it took you longer to get anywhere.
And so she shared with me that when she gone to university,
she'd wanted to be a chemist,
but in her first year was encouraged to drop chemistry and she went into home
economics.
Um,
she couldn't construct those molecules like that spatial representation inside
your head.
It was just impossible for her.
And I really struggled also with organic chemistry because of this difficulty in
university.
Um,
interestingly again say,
well,
I work on a continuum.
I have four brothers and my oldest brother has this at a mild level,
not enough to interfere with him becoming a chemist,
which he did at the University of Toronto,
but he became a physical chemist because it still was hard for him to construct
those molecules.
So what I've learned in this work is that there's no free ride in a sense.
Like if,
if there's a cognitive area of difficulty will have some impact.
It just kind of depends on what it is,
the degree that it's there and what you're doing in your life in terms of,
you know,
whether it has a limit shoe.
So in the work that I've created,
I currently can identify 19 cognitive functions and if people are interested on
our website down here at the bottom,
there's a cognitive profile questionnaire.
I think there's about 250 questions on it.
You can go in and answer these questions.
It's all confidential and at the end,
based on your responses,
it will give you a profile of where it's by your answers.
I'm suggesting that there might be some difficulties and then he'd go on the
website and read more information if if somebody is interested.
So currently we have programs for 19 cognitive functions and I'm very clear that
this isn't everything that can go wrong with learning,
but it's really broad range from,
you know,
the person that struggles with nonverbal interpretation of situations,
face blindness.
I have a program for person that can't reco recognize landmarks.
So cab navigate because they don't remember the look of a place spatial.
The person that gets lost because they can't hold maps or three dimensional
representation,
auditory memory.
The person just can't hold information and numeracy,
the person that doesn't understand number.
So a broad range of,
of different cognitive deficits.
And for me,
um,
you know,
if you're working on an area,
you first need to identify where the problem is.
And if anybody hears somebody say,
um,
you know,
this one problem is going to fix or this one program is going to fix everything
I would say,
you know,
run as quickly as she can.
And the other direction,
because in terms of the brain,
there's no one size fits all.
We have an incredibly complex Oregon here and I believe for something to work
effectively,
it has to be differentiated,
targeted stimulation to that.
Um,
they that function.
And for example,
if we think about reading,
this is a blood flow study looking at all the brain areas that come together
when somebody is reading.
So there is no reading area in the brain.
The brain works in what Larry called a functional system,
what we now call the neural network where multiple areas come together,
each one having its own task.
So there's eye tracking,
there's phonemic awareness,
there's sound symbol,
correspondence to hear the speech towns.
There's the visual memory to hold the speech pattern,
eye tracking to um,
learn kind of a motor plan for the eye,
for reading.
All these are critical.
So if a child or an individual struggling with reading,
it might be any combination of these.
The individuals we work with may have,
you know,
different components.
The individuals we see that really are probably never going to get past the
grade two or three levels of reading unless we do this cognitive work,
have all of these areas impacted.
So there's no piece that they can use to compensate for the difficulties because
every single one related to reading is problematic.
So if you want to see where you are and one of these cognitive functions and you
can keep it confidential,
um,
I think probably everybody in the room here has seen a cat at some time point in
their existence.
Um,
so this is an area in the right hemisphere that holds the look of things.
So if you want to just close your eyes and you don't have to do it,
um,
and see,
can you actually see in your mind's eye or call up on the screen an image or a
picture of a cat.
So whoever wants to to try it
and then if you want to open up your eyes and kind of see how you did.
So some people are going to see like a really vivid,
clear image of,
of,
you know,
the,
the cat.
Some people it will be less clear and some individuals are just going to see the
back of their eyelids.
Um,
and I often call this the refrigerator dysfunction.
this is where the person just doesn't hold the visual details of,
of objects.
Um,
so they open the fridge door and they say,
you know,
where's the mustard?
Where's the ketchup?
So I think you're like ketchup better here.
We like mustard more in Canada.
Um,
um,
and they just,
because you don't hold the picture of what you're looking for or you don't like
shopping.
If somebody has trouble here because you'll walk by what you're looking for
multiple times before you just recognize,
okay,
yeah,
that's the cheerios or whatever it is.
Um,
you miss details.
This will be the person that um,
you know,
their wife maybe goes,
gets a make-over and they don't notice that,
you know,
something is different cause they not holding kind of the visual look of what
was there before and comparing it to what's there.
Now if someone's strong here,
they'll navigate by landmarks.
So go someplace once in the,
remember vividly what it looks like and you know,
where they have to to turn or they're really good with visual imagery.
Um,
I worked with a student that was studying to be an illustrator in Canada and she
had this difficulty,
not massively,
but enough that when she would draw a cat,
she'd leave off the whiskers.
Or when she'd draw a coat,
she'd leave off the buttons.
And that was kind of a problem if you're going to be an illustrator,
um,
because you need to get the details down.
So actually she was one of the first people I created this exercise for and we
worked on that.
She improved this function and now she's won awards in Canada for her
illustrations.
So,
um,
she doesn't miss details anymore.
Uh,
one person I worked with shared with me that she really hated to meditate.
she had this,
and I mean she could do breathing meditation,
but she couldn't do visual imagery meditation.
So someone would tell her to close her eyes and go to her happy place.
Well,
she just saw a black screen.
Um,
so it's,
it definitely doesn't necessarily impact,
um,
the person in school per se and academic learning.
But definitely in life.
If people know Oliver Sacks his book,
the man who mistook his wife for a hat,
that's this cognitive function.
Um,
I have worked with some people that have had traumatic brain injury and one of
the students I worked with your head,
um,
massive right hemisphere damage.
He been hit by a truck when he was 12.
And I saw him when he was in his early thirties,
and the first day he came into my school,
he tried to exit through a filing cabinet because it was rectangular.
It had a handle to him.
It looked like a door.
Um,
we worked on this and what was so amazing,
not only could he eventually recognize objects and landmarks,
um,
but he developed a visual sense of humor cause the whole visual world became
alive for him.
And he could see irony.
Um,
this area is also related to face blindness and face recognition.
so somebody that has a difficulty here,
um,
if they see somebody in context,
so they see some and their neighbor on the porch and the front house,
they'll know who that person is.
Five minutes later they'll see that person in the grocery store,
no idea who they are.
Um,
so I have a program that addresses that and these people often get labeled as
rude or standoffish and that isn't the case.
They just don't recognize the person.
I'm a good friend of mine,
had this difficult and we worked on it and she was a reporter at the Toronto
Star,
which is the second largest newspaper in Toronto.
And for 20 years she rode the elevator up and down,
up and down.
Um,
she had no idea every day that she wanted that elevator.
Did she know anybody on that elevator?
So she said she had two options.
One to just assume she knew nobody and if she offended somebody,
so be it or potentially new everybody.
And if she got labeled as,
you know,
being over friend,
overly friendly.
So that was the option she chose.
But at one point she got accused of being,
um,
prejudicial.
A friend said to her,
you know,
oh,
Linda,
you think all Brown people look alike?
And Linda said to her,
actually,
it's much worse than that.
All people look alike.
But,
but because she didn't recognize people and make that discrimination,
somebody interpreted her behavior as,
as being prejudiced,
which was not accurate.
Um,
so that's this,
this function.
Um,
if you want to try,
this is the same part of the brain,
but now in the left hemisphere.
Um,
so one is holding the look of the thing which is in your right hemisphere.
This is holding the symbol pattern.
So again,
if you want to just think of the word cat,
so the three letters and you want to try and close your eyes and can you conjure
up that,
um,
those three letters on a blackboard.
And again,
some people will see it really crisply.
Some people it will be kind of fuzzy.
And a lot of the students that we work with don't see anything.
They can't hold the visual look of a word.
Some researchers call this the brain's letterbox or visual word,
form area.
I call it symbol recognition.
But it's critical for spelling,
for word recognition,
even learning,
um,
visual symbol templates,
like math formulas,
chemical equations.
We know that you can just learn them visually if somebody has this difficulty.
Um,
they don't,
and I'll just give you an example of the exercise that we use for,
um,
for this area.
So for every single one of the 19 functions,
we have very different exercises because we're targeting very different
functions.
And this language that the student is looking at is m heart from Ethiopia.
And often people say,
well,
you know,
nick is struggling with reading English.
Like why are you giving him Amharic?
Um,
the concept is that we don't want the child or the individual to compensate for
the difficulty.
So if we use English letters,
they could put sound to it,
they could put meaning to it.
If we use m hark or Burmese or Sinhalese or Telegu,
um,
the camp put sound to it,
they can't put meaning to it because they don't know this language.
So the idea of any of the exercises that we're trying to go in and target that
differentiated differentiated stimulation right to the area,
removing any possibility of compensation.
Now you can never fully remove compensation because the brain doesn't work that
way.
So the student goes through a whole process.
There's thousands of levels in each of the exercises.
And by the end of this exercise,
they're holding eight Chinese characters,
excuse me,
in their mind's eye.
And after that,
English actually looks pretty easy.
Um,
but again,
it's not that we're chain or not that we're teaching is skill.
We're changing the brain's capacity to hold symbol patterns.
So what you see changes with this word recognition,
spelling,
visual matching,
visual tracking,
anything related to visual symbol.
I'm learning visual symbol patterns.
And just really quickly if anybody's interested,
we have a number of outcomes studies on our website,
which is Arrowsmith school.org.
Um,
so we've had studies done,
different schools,
different researchers,
different research designs,
all looking at outcomes.
So looking at outcomes on academic measures,
looking at outcomes in schools with rate of learning,
looking at outcomes on cognitive measures.
They're all summarized on the website.
So I'm not going to spend a lot of time on those because you can look at it.
But this was a study done at University of Calgary,
you know,
looking at um,
um,
academic changes.
The one I really like is this was done in the Toronto Catholic District School
Board,
obviously in Toronto.
Um,
and it,
this is a publicly funded board.
We know that students with learning difficulties aren't learning a year for a
year.
So these students were learning about two thirds of a year per year because they
fall further and further behind because they're struggling with their
difficulties.
We took this group of students,
I think they were 60,
60 students,
um,
and we put them half a day doing cognitive exercises.
So they're actually getting less curriculum than they were getting the previous
several years where they were learning two thirds of a year per year.
So now we're reducing their curriculum exposure by half.
And what we found a year after the intervention,
they were doubling and tripling the rate of learning,
having had less academics because we changed the brain's capacity to learn.
I mean,
again,
I keep saying this over and over again,
but this is the power of the brain.
I mean,
you change the capacity of it to learn.
The learning just starts to go forward.
Um,
even when they'd had less exposure,
like these students could have sat in those English classes,
in those math classes,
um,
you know,
for year after year after year,
and they were still going to be learning at two thirds of a year per year.
It needed the cognitive intervention to shift that.
And then we've looked at cognitive measures.
Again,
this was another study done at the University of Calgary and the brain gain lab.
I'm seeing changes on memory,
auditory processing,
fluid reasoning,
um,
as a result of the students working on these cognitive cognitive exercises.
And to me what's most exciting is the research studies that we started,
um,
the last year,
year and a half,
two years ago.
Um,
imaging research because my,
my hypothesis all the way through this work has been,
it's the brain that's changing.
Um,
it made sense.
That was the inference I made when I started this work,
but I didn't have access to this kind of research to do imaging.
It's actually quite expensive.
Um,
so we have a researcher at the University of British Columbia,
just north of here in Vancouver,
Dr. Laura Boyd,
and at the University of Southern Illinois,
Dr Greg rose.
Um,
and we're doing similar studies looking at students with learning difficulties
and the intervention and we're seeing very similar results,
which hopefully within the next year will be published in peer review journals.
Um,
so he had to adapt the reasoning exercise for the scanner because if you've ever
been in an Fmr I like,
you know,
you can barely move,
you'd have to lie.
So,
um,
but what I wanted the researcher do is scan the students prior to intervention
and scan them three months in.
Because what we see with students all around the world in this program is at
about the two to three month mark.
They start to experience cognitive change.
Like they start to be able to do things they couldn't do before.
And parents start to notice that teachers start to notice that people around
them start to notice that.
So I wanted to see what something actually happening in the brain that the three
month mark.
So we can see at time 0.0 with the reasoning exercise,
the brain is processing quite inefficiently,
is taking up a lot of real estate to do that activity.
And again this is very preliminary data.
Um,
and we've got more data.
We've got I think 10 months data now that's being analyzed.
But what we were seeing at three months,
much more efficient processing,
less real estate,
taking up,
taking up to do that reasoning activity as a result of the intervention.
And another thing that we're finding in this preliminary data is,
you know,
if we look at the first,
you take the time activity at one time activity to subtract the two and see is
there something different between the two time points that's consistent.
And what we're seeing is the insula is changing.
It's that little area in the bottom slide that's kind of lit up,
um,
on the left hand side all the way across and all the students doing the
reasoning exercise.
And to me it makes sense because one of the jobs of the insulins to attach
meaning to things,
it's to process information and make sense out of it,
which is what I had difficulty with.
And what that exercise,
um,
shifted for me.
And then what is also really positive is we're seeing change in the prefrontal
Cortex,
the front part of the brain.
I don't know whether this works,
but it's um,
so here you can see at time 0.0,
there's very little prefrontal cortex activation.
And here at time,
at three months,
significant,
this is the most important part of our brain.
This is the part that you probably use everyday in your job.
This is thinking problem solving.
Strategizing is analyzing a situation is,
you know,
you've got a problem in front of you to solve.
And what happens is this is the part of the brain that activates first,
um,
to start to call in resources of how am I going to solve that problem?
What am I going to do?
And then as you're trying to solve the problem,
this is the area that allows you to reflect on the results.
So you know,
this isn't working over here,
what do I have to do?
Like how do I have to modify it?
It's that constant feedback loop as you're solving a problem.
We know students with learning difficulties struggle with that and that's what
we're seeing at the zero time point is they're not using that part of the brain
very efficiently or effectively at time.
Point three,
they're starting to use that and that's what we see behaviorally.
And we see these students become better problem solvers,
better executive functioning.
Um,
so to me it's really exciting that we're seeing the behavior and now we're
actually seeing the most important part of the brain shifting.
We're also doing another study at UBC.
I'm with this researcher and this is working with people with traumatic brain
injury and we just,
uh,
we're just finishing nine months of data collection.
These are individuals that were in car accidents.
Um,
a pretty significant trauma.
I mean,
a lot of them had been in comas.
We got them several years after the traumatic event,
which means any spontaneous remission would happen over the years.
I mean,
my work is designed for people with learning difficulties,
but over the years we had people come in because the brain is the brain with
traumatic injury and we saw our results.
Um,
so we thought,
let's study this.
And especially you can't open the newspaper now without reading about concussion
injuries,
even blast injuries if,
you know,
people coming back from the,
the various,
um,
uh,
war situations.
And what we're finding,
um,
the research actually was just published law or just presented last week in the
Netherlands.
Um,
the research are really excited.
They've got the three month data analyzed.
Um,
they're just starting to analyze a six month data at the end of March will be
the nine month data.
So by July,
um,
we should have publications.
It's just been,
the research has just been accepted in the journal for the frontiers of
neuroscience.
Um,
but we're seeing changes in conductivity,
the same similar kinds of changes that we're seeing in the students with
learning difficulties.
So change in conductivity in the brain.
Um,
some change in Myelin,
which is again,
that that connectivity,
um,
and we're seeing change in what's called fluid cognition.
So the first kind of striped section or the people with a traumatic brain
injury,
um,
you know,
prior to intervention,
the blue or just normal students or individuals without traumatic brain injury
and the red in the middle is where they are three months after.
So you can see they're starting and it's a significant change starting to move
up to normal.
And why is fluid cognition important?
This is that thinking problem solving.
Um,
being able to step into a situation and figure it out and,
and operate in that situation.
So critical for life.
Um,
and we're seeing changes on other measures.
So really I'm very excited.
Um,
because you know,
the work can now be of benefit for people,
not just with learning difficulties but with people with traumatic injury.
And again,
what are some of the areas like auditory memory?
This is the person that goes to the grocery store.
Like you said them out.
Can you buy me three things?
You don't write it down.
You just tell them they come back with only one thing.
Um,
because they can't hold the information or the child that comes home and knows
they have homework but kind of no idea exactly what that homework is because
they can't hold the information and often they get labeled as um,
being irresponsible because they don't do what you ask them to do.
And truly if they have a difficulty here,
they're not irresponsible.
They just can't hold the information.
Um,
I know people that have post it notes all up around their house because they
have this problem.
If they don't have a,
you know,
their their notes or their to do list,
they aren't going to remember what they have to do.
Then number sense or quantity blindness.
I worked,
I've worked with a lot of people,
but one that Kinda stands out was a psychiatrist in Toronto.
Um,
and she would double book clients cause she kind of had no idea of like really
what was 60 minutes.
Um,
it wasn't that she wanted it to make more money by having two clients in the
same time period,
but she just struggled with that.
She struggled with balancing her checkbook.
Um,
I worked with an opera singer that couldn't do time signature and music because
of,
of this area.
We address the cognitive function.
She was able to do her musical theory,
um,
exam.
You know,
the individual that struggles with motor planning.
This was a student,
you know,
they couldn't put their thoughts down on paper.
So we've probably met people like this.
They tell you a story.
It can be really elaborate.
You put a pen in their hand,
nothing much goes down on paper is because they've got the thoughts in the
ideational content.
There's nothing wrong with their thoughts.
It's just the motor system that's translating the thoughts into a motor plan for
writing isn't working properly.
This was the same student 11 months later,
same 10 minutes went on for three pages.
We didn't teach him how to handwrite.
We changed his brain's ability to get his thoughts down on paper.
Um,
just really quickly,
uh,
another area,
um,
this is in the right hemisphere.
This is what one researcher calls cognitive Goldie locks.
We've all met people with this difficulty.
It's where they look at a situation.
Uh,
nonverbal,
a social situation,
they kind of take one clue or cue from that situation.
They don't look at everything going on.
They make an interpretation,
which isn't the full interpretation and then they act on that.
So they get into trouble.
Socially,
they're considered sort of a napped or awkward because they haven't read all the
information and interpreted it correctly.
A good negotiator has to be really strong here because they have to walk into a
negotiation and they have to do that minute by minute reading of what effect am
I getting?
Am I getting,
you know,
the situation to move in the direction I wanted to move.
Um,
an example is if we look at this picture,
I gave it to a 12 year old girl who had really significant social problems.
Nobody in her neighborhood would play with her.
In fact,
everybody said she lies all the time.
Um,
I asked her what was happening in this picture and she told me they were playing
badminton and I asked her why she thought that.
And it's sort of hard to see in this picture,
but this woman has netting on her hat.
And this is severe premature closure.
She looked at the netting,
it triggers an association,
badminton,
that badminton,
they're playing badminton.
She didn't look at all the rest of the information.
So in her nonverbal world,
her social world,
it wasn't that she was lying.
She just misinterpreted things all the time.
And you know,
there are lots of examples.
Another girl looked at this,
she was 18 and she told me they were at City Hall in Toronto and I've been to
city hall many times and I didn't really think it looks quite like that.
And she pointed to the rope in the foreground and she'd been to city hall the
week before and there was an area cordoned off with a rope.
So again,
that premature closure,
she looked at one element,
interpreted it and ran with that interpretation.
In both cases,
we address this cognitive function.
Um,
you know,
the 12 year old is now 30.
She's,
you know,
successful in the world.
She can read nonverbal interpretation,
uh,
so as the,
the other individual.
So again,
we're not teaching them skills or rules because there is no rule book for life.
You've got to go into all these situations and be able to handle the situations
in real time.
And that's what we're giving the brain's ability to do.
Um,
I'm just going to kind of cover this and then open for questions.
I worked with a lot of adults in my school in Toronto and a number of the
schools here,
there's a school in Redmond,
a Eaton Arrowsmith academy that works with adults as well.
And I see a lot of adults that have what I call a cognitive mismatch.
This is where the demands of their job aren't quite aligned with their cognitive
profile.
So if we think about that auditory memory,
I worked with a pilot and airline pilot once and he couldn't hold all of the
instructions for the air from the air traffic controller.
And I've found that a little worrisome,
his was to have their traffic controller repeat the instructions over and over.
But I thought like,
what if you're flying into Chicago hair Atlanta that are really busy airports
and that air traffic control or really doesn't have time to repeat those
instructions and he can't remember them.
So my joke was,
you know,
if I was ever flying,
I want to know what airspace he was flying in so I didn't fly in the same
airspace.
Um,
but the better strategy was addressed,
the problem,
which we did,
and now he can listen to the information once and hold it.
Um,
if we think about that object recognition,
when I call the refrigerator dysfunction,
I worked with the pathologists or he was in doing his residency in pathology at
a teaching hospital in the u s he had that difficulty and he didn't really know
he had that difficulty.
Uh,
he was examining breast tissue.
It was somebody that had had cancer,
breast cancer,
and she'd gone through,
um,
traditional treatments.
She come through chemotherapy and radiation and that was to see what she in
remission.
And he knew how important this was.
So he was really careful.
He was diligent.
He was looking at that slide and it was just about to sign off that the person
was in remission when his supervisor came and said,
didn't you see these cells up here?
This is cancer.
And He,
it's not that he hadn't seen them,
he hadn't recognized them cause he hadn't hold,
held the look to match it up to that.
So he knew he was in serious trouble.
He exited out of his residency program.
We worked on that cognitive function and he now will never make that mistake.
But I think there are a lot of,
um,
what we call human error and some of it can be explained by these cognitive
mismatches,
that kinesthetic,
that problem I had where you don't interpret,
um,
you know,
sensation or register sensation on your left side of your body.
I've had some students that think it's a great idea to get a motorcycle,
um,
and they can't register sensation and don't kind of regulate their body movement
and have a number of accidents,
you know,
on that motorcycle.
Um,
because it plays into,
to that difficulty.
So,
I mean,
what have I learned?
There's every part of the brain is critical.
If anybody says,
you only use 10% of your brain,
tell them,
well,
I'm not going to swear.
Um,
tell them that they're not accurate.
Because over the course of the day,
you use every part of your brain.
And if there's something that's not working in the way that it's designed to
work,
it will have some impact.
Most of us can compensate or we just avoid those things that,
that are hard for us.
Obviously,
a lot of the students that I work with,
I mean from age six,
the oldest person I've worked with is 81.
Um,
these are things where they pile up.
They have multiple areas that are coming together that caused difficulty and
where they cannot really effectively compensate.
Um,
my vision is to get this work,
you know,
starting in grade one,
every child coming to school learns curriculum,
which is what we all do.
But what do we learn with,
we learned with our brain.
So part of their day is devoted to cognitive exercises to stimulate function.
And what would that do?
It would mean the students now that by grade three or four would get identified,
we'll never get identified because by grade three or four,
they'll,
these problems will be addressed.
It'll become a normal part of curriculum.
So there'll be no stigma because there's tremendous stigma still attached to
having a learning difficulty.
Students with unevenness in their profile.
I worked with student,
it's mechanical reasoning was at the 50th percentile,
which is average.
He wanted it to be an architect.
You need to be at the 98th percentile.
I created my mechanical reasoning exercise.
Poor him,
got him to the 98th percentile.
He's now been an architect for 15 years.
That would get addressed,
you know,
in,
in those early grades.
Any child can benefit from cognitive stimulation.
And when I wrote my book,
I put that as my vision at the end of the book.
And I was convinced I would never see that in my lifetime.
Well,
we're in a school in South Carolina,
I call it my whole cohort model,
the whole grade two classes doing two of my cognitive exercises.
This is their second year seeing really good results.
We're just starting in a public school in um,
just north of Sydney in Australia.
They're taking their whole grade one class.
These are just regular grade one.
Kids were doing that motor planning exercise.
Um,
if we go into the university in Spain,
we'll just,
you know,
um,
have all the students working on that reasoning exercise.
So,
um,
the vision is gradually happening and it just has huge applications for changing
the face of education.
And that's what I'm passionate about.
Giving children and young adults and adults a different possibility in their
life.
Like having many more doors open to them and where they can make choice of what
door do I want to walk through rather than having most stores closed and only
one one possibility.
So I just want to thank you and I'm happy to take questions.
[inaudible]
we have a microphone over here for anybody who wants to question or ask
questions,
just raise your hand.
Okay.
Thank you for the talk.
That was a really interesting,
um,
so you emphasize that most of your work is done or focuses on,
uh,
people who have learning disabilities.
[inaudible] uh,
have you tested this,
these same kinds of techniques on,
uh,
patients with Alzheimer's or other sorts of degenerative diseases of the brain?
Yeah,
there's a really good question and I think a lot about that.
The answer is really no,
I haven't.
My concern is if there's a neurodegenerative process,
I don't believe we know enough yet to be able to reverse that.
Um,
there's certainly research coming out that good cognitive stimulation maybe can
stave off the onset by a number of years and there's a lot of good research
looking at people that,
you know,
have to language which ads,
cognitive load,
cognitive complexity,
um,
and the research testing.
Maybe it's five years later that they show the signs if they're going to get
Alzheimer's.
Um,
so I think good cognitive stimulation is positive.
Whether it's going,
I don't just don't think we know enough at this point to say that it's going to
that.
Yeah.
Have you,
have you come across any examples where a learning disability has manifested
itself as a learning super ability in some other context?
I haven't.
I mean,
I've seen really unevenness in profiles where somebody can be exceptional in one
area and have significant difficulty in another.
Um,
but I,
I haven't seen,
you know,
I mean there's this concept that I've heard out there that,
um,
there's a gift of having a learning disability.
I,
I've talked to a lot of people have learning disabilities.
Nobody considers it a gift.
Um,
I mean,
it doesn't mean that maybe it teaches you if you can ways to compensate and work
around,
but I just,
I myself do not see the giftedness and having a learning disability.
It's a struggle.
It causes suffering.
Um,
it,
you just have to work,
you know,
so much harder than everybody else to,
to function.
Now I have seen some students where because of,
you know,
they have a difficult here,
they have a strength here and if they rely on that strength over and over and
over again,
they're probably creating their own cognitive stimulation and they actually
improve that strength.
It doesn't change the learning difficulty.
It improves the strength that they have.
I mean,
for me,
I think I always had a good auditory and visual memory,
but I supercharge them.
I mean my way of studying,
I'd lay my book,
sat on my bed,
um,
as a child,
I would cry from the depths of my soul,
which I was putting my brain and kind of a zen state,
which I didn't know at the time.
Um,
and then I would,
you know,
read the first sentence,
close my eyes,
see it,
read the next sentence,
close my eyes,
see it by the end.
I can look at the first sentence,
I could close my eyes and I could see 50 pages of my notebook.
Um,
I,
I had a good a ability there.
I think I enhance that ability through using it all the time and,
and overusing it.
Hi.
Thanks for being here.
Um,
I was just wondering,
um,
like even in your personal example,
like you go through these training curriculum and then they,
you try to identify the problem and find a solution after the person,
like kind of enhances that ability wherever they were weak.
Um,
is something that you have to do to continue that or is it,
what kind of like if you,
if you don't use it you lose it kind of thing.
Interestingly,
what we see,
cause that's a really good question is there is no dropoff I've tracked myself
and other people have,
you know,
over 30 years out of the program.
And I think why cause I mean we know if we stopped going to the gym,
you know,
our muscles atrophy.
But I think what happens is if we think about that functional system,
like all these areas coming together in a neural network,
if there's some weak areas,
they're acting as a drag on that whole system.
Right?
Once you s you improve them,
enhance them,
they come up and then they get their own stimulation by being,
by being engaged in that,
that neural network.
That's my theory.
I,
it makes sense to me practically what I see is once they've achieved the game,
um,
there's no drop off in function because I believe they're starting to use it in
everyday functioning.
Have you any difference
between children and adults or how neuroplasticity
changes with age?
When I first started this work,
you know,
there was all this research,
there's this beautiful window of neuroplasticity that starts to close at age 12
and you know,
it's kind of all over at age 12.
Um,
so I thought I would see a big difference in,
you know,
the rate of progress in children versus you know,
adolescents,
adults,
young adults.
I haven't seen that.
Like it really was probably the biggest surprise that,
that I've found.
I've seen variability in neuro plasticity,
which makes sense.
There's individual variability and everything and there's a lot of research now
looking at genetics,
looking at what goes into different rates of plasticity.
I mean,
I've got lots of examples in my work where,
you know,
two people come in,
they look very similar in the profile,
same gender,
same age,
do the same amount of work.
They both make progress.
But one goes four times faster than the other,
and then there's probably just more plasticity in that,
that individual.
But um,
you know,
I think about the 74 year old,
retired professor from the medical school at University of Toronto.
She came in,
she had face blind.
It always bothered her,
worked on it.
She made the same progress as a 15 year old.
So to me it's as I'm getting older,
it's really encouraging.
There's neuroplasticity over the lifespan.
Yeah.
Big shout out to Google for the toolkit that you've developed.
It's really enabled us to provide solutions for Barbara and her team that are
very effective.
Uh,
we use the APP engine.
All of our software runs in the APP engine.
Barbara's team is not technologists.
They're educators.
They're scientists,
they're neuroscientists.
They don't run it shops.
Uh,
the cloud has enabled them to deliver seven 24 solutions around the world to
many different countries.
Um,
what we've worked on with them is capturing all that data from those students
that we talked about earlier and analyzing it and coming up with individual
programs for every kid,
every student,
be the adults,
whatever.
And then also tracking their progress through those,
those,
um,
exercises as they're working on it and stimulating their brain,
registering the data from year to year and keeping track of that and producing
reports and report cards.
Um,
and it's your platform that,
that enables that.
Uh,
as the next phase we're going to get into the classroom.
And as we get into the classroom,
there's interactions with the students and interactions based with the teachers,
the teachers and student interactions.
We're going to use the android tablet for that.
And uh,
the Google operating in the android operating system to connect between the
browser,
which we use,
quit the grit toolkit,
a running on APP engine and the Android,
uh,
solutions that are running on the tablet to talk between the teacher and the
student in the same classroom.
So a big shout out,
we're using a lot of tools,
uh,
not to mention the chrome browser.
Um,
and it's working out really well for Barbara and her team.
Thank you.
Uh,
if Americans are more into catch up then Canadians,
then why do they only sell ketchup,
potato chips and Canada?
Sorry,
just kidding.
Oh really?
You don't have ketchup dado chips?
We do not have those here.
Well,
there's no loss.
I do actually have a real question that I'm curious about.
And you mentioned that,
um,
you didn't learn how to read an analog clock until you're 26 and similarly you
didn't,
you didn't understand different sorts of,
uh,
abstract relationships until my plan.
Yup.
I'm wondering where,
where were you in life at that point?
Had you,
had you graduated from college at that point?
Had you already gone to school?
Did you go out and do it after,
after you kind of figured things out?
Yeah,
no,
I,
I'd managed to get up.
I was in graduate school,
um,
but incredible struggle.
Like I,
in my undergraduate I learned the routines of the security guards in the library
cause I would spend all night in the library.
So I would know when they were coming to do their little walkabout.
I would hide out in the wash room.
I worked five days a week or no,
seven days a week,
20 hours,
um,
you know,
every single day just to tread water.
I mean,
that's what it took because I wasn't understanding conceptually,
I was having to rely on memory,
which is really brute force.
Um,
I compromise my immune system.
I have immune system disorder.
There's a lot of research now looking into the field of learning disabilities
and seeing a connection.
Probably it's all the stressors,
um,
that like,
you know,
that affect your endocrinal [inaudible] system.
Um,
so I mean it wasn't just a learning disability.
It affected all sorts of things in my life.
And just before I came across,
um,
the book that was given to me when I was 13,
I attempted suicide,
um,
wasn't successful.
It was kind of that two edge sword,
the despair of having a learning difficulty thinking I've got to go to high
school.
I could barely get through elementary school.
How can I do this?
Um,
so that despair led me to try to end my life.
But my learning disability meant I didn't really understand the instructions of
how you did that.
And I can laugh at it now.
Um,
so I wasn't successful,
but when I woke up the next morning,
cause I thought you did something,
you went to bed,
you just didn't wake up.
When I woke up the next morning,
it was another opportunity to attack myself.
Like I just couldn't even get that right.
But at just before I came across this work,
um,
this time I was planning again and this time I would have gotten it right
because I knew what I had to do.
So that's why I feel like I owe a life debt to Lori is work.
Um,
because that turned my life around.
Like I,
there was no future.
Yes.
I,
you know,
was in graduate school.
Um,
maybe I would've got through.
I'm not sure whether I would have or not.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean there,
there was no,
no life.
I didn't have relationships.
I mean,
I couldn't,
like if I got on an elevator and you know,
my university and one of my professors got on,
I was terrified that they would ask me a question because I wouldn't be able to
understand what they're asking and be able to have a conversation.
Like I lived in terror all the time.
So
just kind of,
I guess in all your research and with working with so many different clients,
um,
any like tips that you would provide just in general for overall cognitive,
albeit a few.
Um,
I do have slides in here,
but I didn't get to them.
I mean,
one of the best things you can do,
exercise,
aerobic exercise,
there's tons of research now.
Like I know you've got bikes here,
you've got walking trails.
Like it doesn't have to be,
um,
more than,
you know,
go out and walk like 30 minutes a day.
A good,
nice brisk walk,
like aerobic exercise.
And the rule is kind of,
it's good for your heart,
it's good for your brain.
Um,
it,
it stimulates,
it's called BDNF,
brain derived neurotrophic factor.
And that generates,
um,
well neurogenesis,
new creating new neurons.
Um,
also it repairs cells,
you know,
like sort of all that damage that happens over time.
So if you can only do one thing,
get out there and you know,
at least five days a week,
do some good aerobic exercise.
Um,
another thing,
reduce stress.
I mean,
all the research is showing now,
um,
that that stress actually is almost like an acid bath for your brain.
I mean,
short term stress,
not a problem is that longterm chronic stress,
um,
which,
actually is,
creates negative neuroplasticity.
It,
you know,
when those dendrites starting to branch,
it actually eats up the dendrites.
Um,
so anything,
whether it's meditation,
you know,
um,
again go sometimes going for a walk,
whatever you can do to reduce stress in your life,
um,
is good for brain health.
Whatever you can do to increase aerobic activity is good for brain health.
And then if you want to,
um,
the other thing that's sort of novelty and cognitive complexity,
which I talked a little bit about.
So let's say you want to learn something new,
what you should do is,
um,
it's,
it's calibrate the level of the challenge,
right?
So let's say,
you know,
I don't know,
you want to learn chess,
but you're not going to start at the grand master level,
right?
Cause if you do,
like,
let's say you're functioning here and you start try to start the activity way up
here,
you aren't gonna be able to engage.
It's not going to drive neuroplastic change if you make it so easy,
the,
as soon as your brain goes on automatic pilot,
and it's not,
I mean the lots of times when you want to be on automatic pilot,
but if you're trying to drive neuroplastic change,
automatic pilot doesn't do it.
So if you're making something too simple,
it's not engaging the brain.
So it's kind of finding that sweet spot,
just like an exercise.
Like,
you know,
if,
if this is where it starts to hurt a little bit,
make it just a little bit more difficult,
then do the activity and then we find it a little step up,
right?
And then make it a little more difficult.
It's calibrating the level of complexity.
Um,
and you can do that in any activity you know,
that you're engaging in,
and that will be the best thing to neuroplastic change.
So exercise,
reduce stress,
and calibrate the level of difficulty in your learning.
Well,
thank you very much.
Okay.
[inaudible].